weil ich versuche mich gerade finanziell
von dir unabhängig zu machen und
deswegen mache ich die bloße Geschäfte
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
mein Team hat sich eine herzhafte Tat
gewünscht eine Quiche sozusagen ich weiß
wenn Murat das Wetter hört Quiche und
tat das mag gar nicht so gerne
vielleicht können wir auch gemeinsam
einen anderen Namen dafür finden aber es
ist Herbst es kommt bald der Winter und
wir haben einfach Lust auf was schönes
herzhaftes und eine Tat bzw eine Kirsch
ist einfach mega lecker ich mache das
jetzt heute nicht aus einem Mürbeteig
sondern aus einem Quark-Öl-Teig weil es
schneller geht und so ein bisschen
leichter ist als ein sehr guter Teig
also hier schon mal die Zutaten ich
verwende dafür 350g Mehl plus Backpulver
oder ihr nehmt das backmehl etwas Salz
200 g Quark 2 Eier und 40 g Olivenöl das
war's und hier gibt's auch nichts zu
beachten ihr packt einfach alle Zutaten
in die Rührschüssel und alles wird schön
und kurz miteinander verknetet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
komm wir lassen ihn die Tür rein
wow richtiger Sahara Staub wir haben
Fenster
hello
danke schön ich habe ein äußerst netter
Postzusteller
perfekt wenn er ein bisschen zu weich
ist einfach noch Mehl dazu aber ich
finde da ist super dann kann man dann
gut ausrollen okay den lasse ich jetzt
hier einfach kurz in der Rührschüssel
und werde schon mal die Füllung
zubereiten ich habe mich jetzt hier für
eine hackfleisch-lauch Füllung
entschieden mit Champignons und
Hackfleisch deswegen damit ich das Murat
so ein bisschen besser erklären kann
warum es heute eine Quiche gibt
[Musik]
dafür nehme ich 400 Gramm Hackfleisch
vom Rind 1 bis 2 Stangen Porree etwas
Olivenöl Mehl 160 g Champignons frischen
Thymian oder auch getrockneten jeweils
200 g Sahne und Milch Salz und Pfeffer
Muskatnüsse und hier noch 150 Gramm
Schafskäse und zum Abbinden nehme ich
noch einen Becher Schmand oder saure
Sahne und ein Ei ich habe jetzt hier
einen großen gusseisenbräter da kann ich
nämlich alles richtig schön schnell
anbraten da kommt noch direkt Olivenöl
mit rein und dann kann es schon mal warm
werden und Hackfleisch kann angebraten
werden
solange das noch ganz kurz aufheizt das
geht aber eigentlich recht schnell kann
ich schon mal hergehen
und den Porree schneiden den wasche ich
immer äußerlich erstmal ab schneide ihn
dann in feine Ringe und dann schleudere
ich ihn mit der Salatschleuder denn dann
bekomme ich auch den Sand raus also ich
wasche den quasi nach dem Schneiden
[Musik]
schön füllen wir nicht anbraten
in der Zeit gehe ich den porreewaschen
[Musik]
mein Hackfleisch dann krümelig ist so
wie jetzt hier gebt ihr die Porree
Stücke dazu
deswegen verzichte ich jetzt hier auch
auf eine Zwiebel weil er Porree einfach
schon zwiebelig ist
da müssen wir mal aufpassen wenn die
Lüftung nämlich so stark ist dann zieht
es dir so während des Flugs die Zutaten
einfach rein
dann kann das hier weiter braten und ich
kann die Champignons fein schneiden
da immer drauf achten dass man die nicht
wäscht weil sie ansonsten zu viel Wasser
aufsaugen deswegen wirklich immer nur
trocken abarbeiten und dann sind die
auch sauber
[Musik]
da gebe ich jetzt hier noch Mehl dazu
das bindet dann nämlich die Soße
und jetzt kann ich hier die Milch
aufgießen dann löst sich auch hier das
Wasser unten so ein bisschen anbrennt
aber es brennt ja nicht an weil ich ja
nicht die höchste Stufe habe sondern das
sind einfach Röstaromen die Zutaten und
wenn ihr das jetzt hier mit der Milch
aufgehst dann löst sich alles wieder
schön vom Herd vom Topf vorne
dann auch die Sahne dazugeben und jetzt
lasse ich es noch ganz kurz aufkochen
und würzt das ganze jetzt schon mal mit
Salz Pfeffer und etwas frisch geriebener
Muskatnuss und beim Salz ist jetzt
tatsächlich bisschen aufpassen weil er
noch scharfkäse dazu kommt damit jetzt
nicht zu salzig wird und das sage ich
als Salz aber wirklich erstmal nur eine
Prise dazu geben da kann man immer noch
abschmecken
und weil es gut passt ist noch Thymian
den habe ich jetzt noch draußen von der
Terrasse aber ihr könnt natürlich auch
getrocknet nehmen das passt auch gut
Majoran passt auch gut nehmt einfach
Gewürze die ihr gerne habt
und dann kann man eigentlich den Herd
schon runterstellen
die Brösel jetzt auch den Käse direkt
hier rein
[Musik]
die Füllung ist jetzt fertig und ich
verrühre jetzt hier noch den Schmand mit
dem Ei das bindet später die Soße dann
auch noch ein bisschen besser
einmal kurz verrühren
[Musik]
dann ist jetzt schon direkt der Teig an
der Reihe den Ofen habe ich jetzt auch
schon vorgeheizt
ich brauche jetzt nur ein bisschen mehr
dann forme ich eine schöne Kugel weil
wenn so der die Ausgangsform einer Kugel
ist dann lässt es halt auch besser
arbeiten deswegen mache ich immer vorher
da kann ich nämlich auch schöner
ausräumen
und ich habe jetzt hier eine Tarteform
die hat 30 cm Durchmesser ist auch mit
einem hebelboden damit ich später die
Tat gut rausbekommen ich muss sagen ich
verstehe keine tatformen ohne hebelboden
weil man ja dann die rausstürzen muss
sondern geht die Tat kaputt deswegen
hier mit Hebel Foto mit Löchern damit
das schön durchpackt und knusprig wird
also schön perforiert
und der 30 cm dann will ich ja noch den
Rand das heißt ich rolle meine Teig etwa
also 34 bis 36 cm groß aus und zum
Quark-Öl-Teig ist halt super weil der
eben einfach geht und leichter schmeckt
alles in Mürbeteig
[Musik]
die Tarteform könnt ihr dann mit
backtrennspray einsprühen
dann rolle ich den Teig auf den Auslauf
und kannst direkt in die Form legen
muss er sagen Quark-Öl-Teig ist gerade
so für back Einsteiger ich der beste
Teig der Reis nicht der bricht nicht
perfekt
hier schön anpassen bisschen ran drücken
mit einer kleinen Palette könnt ihr dann
hier den Teig am Rand wegstreichen
dann habt ihr einfach so einen perfekten
Abschluss
Teigreste das verteile ich jetzt hier
einfach so Hauptsache schmeißt nichts
weg und jetzt fülle ich hier einfach die
Füllung rein
[Musik]
bitte einfach hier diesen Schöpfer
würdigen in der Küche diese Schöpfkelle
denn bis zum letzten Rest hier zack zack
zack hier
einfach perfekt
so jetzt verteile ich hier die Füllung
schön die hier einfach perfekt rein
passt
gutes Augenmaß Frau
hier dann verteile ich hier so ein paar
schöne obendrauf denn ich will dass es
noch ein Backen auch schön aussieht das
heißt super Champignons ein bisschen
Lauch
wunderschön und dann kommt die Tarte in
den Backofen
[Musik]
etwas abkühlen lassen jetzt kann ich sie
rauslösen
und dann kann Murat probieren
so hier bin ich
komme gerade ich komme gerade von der
schwarzbaustelle ja ich stehe schwarz ja
die schwarz-weiß ich versuche mich
gerade finanziell von dir unabhängig zu
machen und deswegen mache ich die Biose
Geschäfte und habe gerade einen
Rollrasen gelegt bei Johannes super das
machst du wundervoll
unabhängig von dir und lassen sie mir
auch nichts mehr sagen okay finde ich
super
okay
mit Hackfleisch
ja das ist eigentlich eher selten
aber es hat sich sowieso eingependelt
ja jedenfalls habe ich immer gedacht
mache ich dir mal eine Freude wenn du so
hart arbeiten warst dann mach deine
Ehefrau dir natürlich eine Freude und
packt dir einen leckeren ein leckeres
Mittag ich habe mein Geld unterwegs
verloren das Schwarzgeld
Kartoffeln
die Schreibweise mit ch hat
mich gerade
Unterschied nicht
wie deine Hackfleisch Lauchsuppe ja ich
hatte auch tatsächlich Lust auf einen
der schlauchsuppe und dann habe ich die
gemacht
Hammer
bei der Kombination Pilze Hackfleisch
und Lauch ja das hört sich immer komisch
an aber es schmeckt richtig genial
danke schön
der wohnt in der
der wohnt in der Mozartstraße und der
Turgut lass mich gerade in der
Beethovenstraße Wahnsinn also das Rezept
findet ihr auch
blog.de
und der hat mich irgendwie jetzt
komplett verwirrt aber egal wir lassen
den Abschluss einfach verwirrt
wenn ihr nicht schwarzbaustelle habt
schreibt ihr eure Telefonnummer in die
Kommentare ich kontaktiere euch das
genau
oder perfekt und
die Geldbeträge natürlich im Umschlag
wieder auf den Schweizer Geldkonto oder
direkt auf die keimmalinsel im pazifiki
oder Dubai Dubai Duba genau
also eins können Sie sagen
Lüge tut der Murat nicht
[Musik]